SCP-049 is a fascinating bundle of contradictions.
Arguably, he’s the Hannibal Lecter of the
anomalous world: He’s educated, refined,
and cultured.
A scientific man with scientific goals, capable
of communicating eloquently in both English
and Medieval French.
As anomalies go, he’s one of the more cooperative
ones contained by the SCP Foundation, willing
to understand reason and even showing a small
degree of respect for his “fellow” researchers.
And yet, despite all this intelligence and
refinement, underneath his dark, organic cloak,
a heart of deep red violence steadily beats.
He’s capable of ending life with a mere
touch - causing all biological functions in
the body to simply cease through means that
are still unknown to science, thanks to a
series of inconclusive autopsies on SCP-049’s
unaltered victims.
Not only is killing easy in a physical sense
for SCP-049, with a few notable exceptions,
it’s also been just as easy on his conscience.
Such is the danger of the man or monster who
believes unshakably that his goals are righteous:
Any moral crime is permissible if done in
service of seeing them through.
And for those who die at SCP-049’s hand,
an even greater indignity awaits: His inhuman
experiments, the gateway to a second life
as an abominable crime against nature.
A glob of malignant spit in the eye of God.
But let’s not get too ahead of ourselves
here, students.
We’ve mentioned SCP-049 countless times
in passing before.
Some of his strange tales, his interactions
with other anomalies like SCP-682, and even
with some of your questions and theories about
this bone-masked scientific madman.
And yet, he still remains a mystery.
Perhaps, to truly understand this fascinating
walking question, we need to return to the
beginning and give the classified files behind
the Plague Doctor a closer look.
Like many of the most infamous anomalies discovered
by the SCP Foundation, the files indicate
that the discovery itself was first triggered
by a series of mysterious disappearances in
the sleepy town of Montauban, out in Southern
France.
People across races, classes, ages, and genders
were simply falling off the map, suggesting
a highly indiscriminate assailant.
Little did the Foundation know, in the beady
avian eyes of their killer, they all had an
extremely important commonality: Each and
every one of them was infected with The Pestilence.
The Invisible Scourge, The Great Dying.
Their killer was the only one with the proper
diagnostic mind to even notice the infection.
He was the only one who could save the world
from this insidious, unseen threat.
And then the SCP Foundation discovered his
laboratory.
The Plague Doctor had been doing his delicate
work in an abandoned house on the edge of
town.
The kind of place that gets whispered about
in local rumors.
A bad place.
A cursed place.
Little did they know, it was only the latest
in a long line of covert research centers
for this singularly inspired medicine man.
While some of the details were a little foggy
in his memory, he’d been carrying out his
work for a little over 400 years now, moving
from place to place, causing strings of disappearances
wherever he showed up.
In his own words, he’s an extremely well-traveled
man.
And still, the cure for that blasted Pestilence
continued to evade him.
He sat in that decrepit Montauban house, surrounded
by groaning, writhing abominations of his
own creation, taking meticulous notes.
Nothing would break his concentration, not
even the strangers in black tactical gear
with large guns kicking in his front doors.
His many Cured patients didn’t take kindly
to the intrusion on their treatment and decided
to swarm the interlopers.
What followed was a violent struggle between
the Intruders and the Cured, resulting in
several of the Intruders injured and all of
the Cured dead once more.
During all this chaos, the Plague Doctor never
once stopped taking notes.
When he was finished with his sentence, he
willingly submitted to capture by this mysterious
“SCP Foundation.”
After all, when he told them about the true
nature of his mission, they would of course
see reason and allow him to continue his research.
Sure, he may have committed a few crimes against
nature on the way, but he was working in service
of loftier ideals…
You can only imagine his profound relief when
he was first interviewed by SCP Foundation
Researcher Dr. Raymond Hamm in Site-85.
He was in the presence of fellow scholars,
people of science!
He worried at first that he’d been captured
by some group of common street scoundrels,
when in fact, the hands of providence had
delivered him into the perfect place to continue
his research.
The warm light of fate was now smiling on
him after so long languishing in the dark.
All he needed to do was allow the scientists
around him to conduct tests on his own body
while he conducted tests on others.
At first, the SCP Foundation believed that
he was an anomalous human being wearing a
costume, but they soon discovered that he
was something very different.
What they thought was a mask was actually
an outgrowth of his skull, a kind of insect-like
exoskeleton.
The robes were also a component of his body,
a kind of thick hide that developed over the
years.
The thickness of the hide itself also made
him impervious to a great deal of physical
damage.
Despite his politeness, research notes on
the Plague Doctor indicated that Foundation
personnel found interacting with him “uncanny.”
There was an oddly eerie quality to him.
Something indistinguishable that just felt
off.
The Foundation also found that the Plague
Doctor, whom they initially addressed as “Doctor”
rather than SCP-049 out of a sense of mutual
respect, also came with a number of strange
personal effects.
These included a long pointing stick, similar
to the ones used by medieval plague doctors
to touch things without fear of contamination.
This stick was soon confiscated.
It didn’t possess any anomalous qualities,
but the Plague Doctor had a tendency to gesture
grandly with it as he spoke, and the Foundation
feared he’d absentmindedly take someone’s
eye out with it if he wasn’t careful.
The other two personal effects that the Plague
Doctor prized greatly was his old-fashioned
medical bag and the notebook that he obsessively
recorded his observations with.
The medical bag, which seemed to exhibit anomalous
properties, contained a mix of archaic medical
tools as well as some that the Foundation
has been unable to identify.
It’s through the tools in this bag that
the Plague Doctor is able to create instances
of SCP-049-2.
As we alluded to earlier, the Plague Doctor
can kill with a touch, but that’s only part
of what he does to his victims.
After causing all their biological functions
to cease, he takes the tools out of his medical
bag and begins performing crude surgery on
their corpse - Including using a syringe to
inject an unknown anomalous liquid into their
flesh.
While the specifics of the Plague Doctor’s
modifications can vary from victim to victim,
the result is often the same: They’re converted
into strange, shambling abominations that
aren’t capable of any kind of higher thought.
For the most part, their movements are extremely
basic and limited.
However, if they’re provoked, they can become
frighteningly violent, more than capable of
killing an armed Foundation guard if they
don’t remain alert during the engagement.
The SCP Foundation was given a unique opportunity
to understand more about SCP-049’s twisted
experiments: As part of his conditions for
containment, they agreed to provide the diabolical
doctor with a number of fresh test subjects.
The Doctor was eager to continue his work,
and through watching him work, the SCP Foundation
could learn a great deal more about him.
Though we wouldn’t even pretend that the
Plague Doctor’s work has ever been enjoyable
to watch.
They presented him with some live subjects
and a much greater number of mammalian corpses.
He would spend several days working intensely
on each one, then documenting his findings
in his precious notebook.
As a mark of respect for the Foundation scientists
around him, the Plague Doctor was more than
eager to share his research with them and
compare notes.
He was always a talkative one, perhaps just
excited to discuss his experiments and theories
with “like-minded” scholars after so many
years of working alone.
Here are four notable instances.
First, the Plague Doctor was presented with
a live D-Class specimen.
He thanked the Foundation greatly for this
gift, then set about his work.
He asked the unaware D-Class several questions
about his medical history while retrieving
tools from his bag, before quickly touching
and killing the man.
He performed extensive modifications on the
D-Class corpse, and when he was resurrected
as an SCP-049-2 instance, he was barely recognizable
as his original form.
He was a bizarre, flailing creature, constantly
groaning and gasping from the oblong-shaped
hole that the Plague Doctor had carved into
his chest.
While performing this horrifying work, the
Plague Doctor eagerly remarked to the observing
researchers that the cure appears to be extremely
effective.
Next, he was provided the corpse of a recently
deceased goat, which he also expressed gratitude
for.
After performing surgery on the creature,
it was successfully resurrected into a bizarre
SCP-049-2 instance.
However, the Plague Doctor readily admitted
that this definitely wasn’t his best work,
commenting, “The disease was still in its
nascent stage.
My veterinarian practice is rudimentary, but
the patient responded well to the procedure.”
Next, he was provided the corpse of a recently
deceased orangutan.
The Plague Doctor was delighted by this - Commenting
that, given primate similarities to human
physiology, this would be the next best thing
from a true human test subject.
However, this research became surprisingly
fraught.
He killed and reanimated the beast four different
times, seemingly unsatisfied with the result
each time, and when he failed to reanimate
the creature a fifth time, he seemed disconcerted.
In a debriefing discussion, the Plague Doctor
said:
“I have learned so much from this, though
I fear my early optimism was misplaced.
I hadn’t yet come across such a… a stumbling
block on my road to the cure.
More subjects like this would do a great deal
in advancing my research.”
Next, it was provided with the corpse of a
recently deceased cow.
This irritated SCP-049, who wanted test subjects
who were physiologically closer to humans.
Still, despite his frustration, he continued
his work.
He only took brief breaks to enjoy a meal
of hard cheese, salted pork, and thin crackers.
Tests showed that SCP-049 didn’t require
sustenance to survive, but he enjoyed the
act of eating and found that it helped him
with his work.
He embalmed the cow, rearranged its organs,
and even inverted its head.
However, this didn’t impede his work.
He injected it with a variety of liquids,
which he described as the essence of the humors.
When asked to elaborate further on this, he
said,
“The Pestilence may bring about a systemic
imbalance.
In such a case, before true healing can begin,
one must find the humors in balance or the
body will reject the cure.
This is, of course, elementary knowledge for
the practical physician.
I would have thought you would have learned
this during your education!”
After being provided a working cattle prod
to introduce a little electricity into the
equation, the Plague Doctor successfully reanimated
the mutant cow.
From here, things started to go downhill.
Dr. Hamm decided to conduct another interview
with SCP-049, hoping to get into the finer
details of his scientific process.
However, they hit some major roadblocks: SCP-049
seemed to be unable to actually articulate
the true nature of The Pestilence or his processes
in seeking the cure.
Even his notebook wasn’t written in any
known language and proved impossible to decipher.
As the interview went on, the Plague Doctor
seemed to become increasingly distressed,
insisting on the importance of his work to
helping the human race prosper and survive
this terrible plague.
All he needed in exchange was more test subjects.
The practiced civility that had been built
up between the Plague Doctor and the SCP Foundation
crumbled in 2017, after a tragic incident
in the Plague Doctor’s cell with Dr. Hamm.
When he entered to perform a very standard
interview with the Plague Doctor, the Doctor
appeared to become anxious and asked Dr. Hamm
if he was feeling well today.
Dr. Hamm thought nothing of it and tried to
continue the interview, but by that point,
it was already too late.
The Plague Doctor had come to believe that
Dr. Hamm was infected with The Pestilence.
And of course, there was only one cure.
The Plague Doctor gave Dr. Hamm his touch
of death.
The man died instantly, and the Plague Doctor
immediately went about turning his corpse
into another SCP-049-2 instance.
Because Hamm was killed so quickly, he didn’t
have time to activate his emergency security
signal, meaning what was left of him wasn’t
discovered until three hours later.
Guards and researchers were horrified to see
one of their own turned into a mindless, deformed
monster by an anomaly they all thought they
could trust.
Following this tragic incident, Dr. Theron
Sherman chastised the Plague Doctor for this
appalling breach of trust, and the cold-blooded
murder of Dr. Raymond Hamm.
The Plague Doctor, in a state of increasing
distress, insisted that Hamm was infected,
and he did all he could to cure him.
And while the Plague Doctor insisted a certain
level of scientific distance from his subject,
it seemed that, deep down, he regretted the
loss of a friend and fellow researcher in
his endless quest against the Pestilence.
After this incident, the Plague Doctor truly
became SCP-049.
He lost all of his privileges and now remains
under lock and key in Site-19.
Whenever he’s transported, he’s kept in
shackles and supervised by a number of armed
guards.
After discovering that the scent of lavender
has a pacifying effect on him, it’s regularly
used as a tranquilizer against him during
engagements.
This is how a cordial ally can become just
another prisoner in the eyes of the SCP Foundation.
In a summary interview after the Dr. Hamm
incident, Dr. Elijah Itkin asked if 049 had
any regrets about the incident, noting that
he seemed oddly mournful.
049 paused, before replying,
“Mourn…
Perhaps.
I had not thought that…
It is lamentable that a fellow doctor became
infected, but the work continues.
Regrettable as… as it was, Dr. Hamm's death
provided important insight.
Living human subjects are the only way to
proceed forward, I am decided.
My cure is of little use on dead flesh, and
I have gleaned all I can from your generous
supply of corpses.
My desires turn towards tending to those still
living who suffer from the disease.”
Dr. Itkin replied that 049 would be disappointed
on that front.
He just laughed in response, and replied,
“Oh, Doctor, I wouldn’t be so sure…”
Now go check out “SCP-049 - What Actually
is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”
and “SCP-049 - Going Home” for more on
the enigmatic plague doctor, SCP-049!